The for statement up here, indeed, controls whether this entire block is executed or not.
Therefore, it also controls whether B is executed or not.
If this condition holds, then tag is set to true.
If it does not hold, execution resumes for the remaining conditions.
And therefore, this if condition also controls whether this is executed.
Same thing happens for the other condition.
The last condition, however, only controls whether the character
will be edited out or not.
It has no influence on whether code is being set or not.
Therefore, this statement does not influence whether B is executed or not.
B is not control dependent on it.